foreign
antibodies antibody immunity whether
antibody immunity is the
um the best kind of immunity that one
might uh want to induce with a vaccine
campaign there is also this interesting
paper that showed up in nature I only
briefly saw it before we went on today
but it's clearly relevant
um Zach do you want to put on that uh
that paper
uh yep
um so this is a report this is nature
um
and it talks about something which
people who have been watching Dark Horse
for some time will remember you and I
talked about earlier much earlier in the
pandemic the possibility that there
might be hybrid herd immunity that comes
from some people uh having received
their immunity through an inoculation
some people having that immunity through
exposure to the pathogen and that really
were the inoculations good at producing
a uh an immunity to Contracting the
disease that you could get there by a
combination of those two processes well
I haven't seen this paper yet but it
looks from just what I can see of the
abstract here that they at least looked
not just antibody response but also T
Cell response yep they did now scroll
down Zach if you would towards the end
of the abstract
[Music]
um
it says his full vaccination was crucial
to provide hybrid immunity right what
you have to say if you're going to
publish in nature
um however when designing vaccine
strategies T Cell exhaustion after
multiple vaccinations should be
considered this is literally the first
time I've seen this paper yep
have you seen it enough to know on what
basis they are saying you know that that
looks encrypted that looks encoded to be
like okay we had to say these things and
we're going to be a little bit cryptic
here but what did they see what did they
made them conclude that you know T Cell
exhaustion after multiple vaccinations
should be considered which like given
the way abstracts are written now on
this topic that sounds like this is what
we found but we only you're able to say
maybe this right what they saw was a
substantial drop in T Cell reactivity
after multiple boosts by the vaccines
and the reason that I refog and T cell
are dropping uh igg4 is increasing which
is an attenuation signal so yeah the the
right right I got a sine problem I gotta
keep track of the signs but igg4 is
increasing which is causing a drop in uh
responsiveness right and separately
T-cell responsiveness is dropping in
multiply inoculated people now
the implications of that are likely to
be
complex hard to parse but one thing at
the level of the discussion that we've
just had what this looks like is that
these particular inoculations whether
the people who designed and or produced
them knew what they were doing or not
seems to be dragging the uh battle
against SARS cov2 in those who have
subjected themselves at least to the
MRNA vaccination campaign dragging the
fight into the realm of V cells and
antibodies and away from T cells right
now
people who have studied viruses are
liable to be alarmed at that because
viral immunity over on the T Cell side
is likely to be superior and so this is
yet another variation on a theme didn't
see that exact result coming but we have
talked about things like
original antigenic sin original
antigenic sin means that once you've
given the immune system a potent message
about a particular pathogen the immune
system loses its objectivity it loses
its creativity and it becomes tracked
into making that first response that it
made and that is not a good thing right
you want the immune system to be dynamic
to be capable of Switching gears if it
needs to and tracking it into this one
response is not a good idea so that's
original antigenic sin there is antibody
dependent enhancement
in which a pathogen
utilizes the antibodies that it can
predict are going to land on its surface
as a mechanism for gaining access to
cells that it would not be otherwise
able to do and you know now we've got
attenuation signals right attenuation
signals uh are not in either of those
categories exactly but does seem like a
consequence of something analogous to
Original natogenic Sin
um and now we see T cells uh standing
down that's like you know is that a
consequence of an attenuation signal
what is it but in any case it's uh
it is so many different demonstrations
of what you and I said very simply
without
um any specificity at all right welcome
to complex systems you are intervening
in a
interaction between a pathogen and the
immune system that's one complex system
inside of a person that's another
complex system inside of a society in in
a pandemic okay but but that description
and we have said that multiple times by
that description so too is any vaccine
right so any any vaccine is going to
actually have those three layers of of
complexity
um that that is true about it and you
know what isn't included in the
rendering that you just gave is the
novelty up upon novelty upon novelty I
think there's at least three
um in the MRNA vaccines like you know
there are at least well yes so it's the
MRNA being used to effectively turn you
into a factory for the antigen yep it's
the introduction of the pseudo-uridine
into the MRNA so it doesn't Decay and
it's the lipid nanoparticles uh that are
coding the MRNA so that they aren't
found by the
rnases yeah right um in the
intracellular space to to also not let
them Decay so all all three of those
things and I'm I'm sure there are many
more than that but those are the three
that come to mind like oh this is this
is so novel with no track record right
um so I will just put an asterisk on
that last one the lipid nanoparticles
are in and of themselves uh novel and
who knows what their consequence is but
the lack of a targeting mechanism so
that whatever they're doing is just
happening all over the body is a
critical design failure right um but
I agree with you it the nested complex
systems are always there it's the
intervening with something novel and
thinking that you know what's going to
happen oh no you don't right the best
thing you can do is you can work in a
way that is close is closely enough is
similar enough to something you've done
and seen the response and hopefully
tracked the consequences over the course
of decades following that gives you some
confidence that this works but even that
we've seen we've seen traditional
vaccines fail right you've seen them
introduced and we've seen safety signals
cause them to be removed from the market
and so the point is that's not foolproof
but at least it's something yeah right
and here what they did was an absolutely
at least triply novel intervention in a
nested series of complex systems where
you know it's just
obvious that they weren't going to be
able to predict the outcome and you know
it is much worse than it might have been
uh so far it's not as bad as it might
have been you know it's arbitrary in
terms of its level of terribleness but
it you know
it was very unlikely that with that
level of novelty in that level of
complexity that their hopes were going
to be mirrored by the consequence and we
we've seen them uh embarrassed or at
least they should be embarrassed at uh
at what actually happened no I don't I
don't see any evidence of embarrassment
honestly
um we are seeing more and more
suggestions uh that it is not as uh
those who are actually trying to help
Humanity would have hoped
but the evidence of embarrassment on
behalf of uh those who push these things
I don't see
I don't see it
[Music]